mais obama est venu à l'hôpital notre
dame de montréal pour un examen de
routine le stationnement lui a coûté 17
$ pour deux heures je pouvais trouver
une place et les rues alors c'est ce que
je dois faire avec un tarif maximal de
24 dollars pour 24 heures ce
stationnement est l'un des plus chers au
québec
je trouve pas ça normal qu'on paye
stationnement quand qu'on va rendre
visite à quelqu'un qui tape je pense que
c'est déjà assez dur
on n'a pas besoin de ça en plus la cac
s'est pourtant engagé en campagne
électorale à plafonner les tarifs de
stationnement au québec
les tarifs ne seront pas plus élevés que
de 7 à 10 $ majorée en fonction du temps
qu'il passera
l'association québécoise des retraités
des secteurs public et parapublic crois
qu'après dix mois au pouvoir
il est temps que le gouvernement legault
agissent quand tu arrives des problèmes
de santé
on est obligé de se présenter dans un
centre hospitalier 20 km puis qu'on doit
débourser de 16 à 24 dollars par jour ça
finit par peser lourd sur le
portefeuille
les plus récentes données montrent que
les stationnements d'hôpitaux demeure
une source de profits importants à lui
seul les stationnements du sus de l'est
de l'île de montréal ont rapporté plus
de 4 millions huit cent mille dollars
dans la dernière année on a une
gouvernance il temps de faire mieux les
choses pour ne jamais fait et de rang
des stationnements gratuits
à québec on admet que la promesse n'a
pas encore été remplies faute d'argent
le cabinet de la ministre mais cannes
explique que des stationnements sont
souvent gérées par des fondations et
qu'il serait injuste d'imposer un tarif
maximal qui fait diminuer leurs revenus
sans leur offrir de compensation le
premier budget girard ne prévoyait
aucune somme pour remplir cette promesse
et la caq maintient que son engagement
sera respectée en cours de mandat en
attendant le sous ministre de la santé a
transmis une lettre aux établissements
pour leur demander de geler leurs tarifs
de quoi donner un peu de répit à des
usagers qui en ont souvent bien besoin
ici jérôme l'abbé radio canada montréal